For trivial health problems like pain,
common cold and so on...
it's not advisable to have medicines unnecessarily.
But many a time doctors encounter patients
requesting medicines for such trivial problems.
So once,
a smart doctor just gave some sugar pills as medicine to them.
And surprisingly,
the patients reported feeling better after consuming the pills.
So what miraculous power did these sugar pills have?
Let's find out !
This effect was because of a psychological phenomenon
called the Placebo Effect.
What does it mean?
Here the patients were given sugar pills,
but they thought that they were actually receiving real medicines.
So they had a positive mindset
that since they had taken medicine
they would feel better.
And this led to a positive effect on their health.
This is the Placebo Effect.
Now let's see another interesting example.
Some runners in a race were told
that they were given 'Super Oxygenated Water',
while it was just plain water.
But surprisingly these runners ran much faster than usual.
This led to the runners positive mindset
and they out did themselves.
Pretty intriguing right!
In the first example that we saw, sugar pills did the trick
while in the second, it was the water.
They are called Placebos.
So can you think of the applications of a Placebo Effect?
Give it a shot.
Placebo Effect plays an important role in the medicinal field.
It's used to test the effectiveness of a new drug.
Let's say there's an organization
which has come up with a new pain killer
and wants to check its effectiveness.
Some of the volunteers in a research trial
are given a Placebo while the others the actual medicines.
Now if the volunteers taking the actual drug
demonstrated a significant improvement
over those taking the placebo,
then it means the drug is effective
and we can use it as medicine.
In this way,
it can be figured out if the new drug actually has any effect
or if it's just another Placebo.
We saw that a Placebo can be any substance
that does not have any direct effect,
but it's used to change someone's mind set.
Now let's see one interesting example
where we don't even have to use a physical substance as a Placebo.
Normally a 30-minute exercise every day
is enough for a human to lead a healthy life.
This is easy for people whose work involves physical activities,
like housekeeping.
But according to the study, it has been seen
that many housekeepers do not perceive their job as an exercise.
So, one interesting experiment was conducted
with female house keepers.
The women were grouped in two.
Group one was given a presentation
where it was told that the activities they indulge in at work,
are actually good exercises.
And the other group wasn't given this piece of information.
After a few weeks to see the result of the presentation,
these women were tested on a few parameters.
Surprisingly, the women from group one
showed quite a drop in body fat
blood pressure, and were healthier.
But the ones from group two
didn't show any significant changes.
So what do you think happened here?
This example takes us to a conclusion
that Placebo need not be any physical substance,
it can be anything that our mind believes in!
Even if it's just a thought.
Now here,
just the thought that they were receiving a
good amount of exercise while they worked
changed their mindsets towards their job.
And this resulted in a positive change in their health.
Interesting, isn't it?
We now know that having the right mindset matters.
Mindset effects our performances and abilities.
Now we all have a common notion
that some of our abilities are innate.
For example, many of us think
that people are either born intelligent or they are not.
We believe that the great scientists were born intelligent.
So is intelligence an innate ability?
Instead of having this fixed mindset,
can we improve our intelligence by changing our mindset?
This is your Kyu Box to explore.
Share your findings in the comments section.
And if this video has succeeded in changing your mindset,
then do not forget to share this video,
and do subscribe to our channel.